الولايات المتحده من جانبها تحاول على ما
يبدو احتواء الحرب لدر امازيد من
التداعيات
قال ان الفرصه سمحت لبلاده
لتواصله على مستويات عليا مع الروس من اجل
خفض المخاطر وتقليصي فرص اي استخدام محتمل
للاسلحه النوويه وتوضيح عواقب استخدامها
اكد على بث جهود كبيره خلال اشهر الماضيه
لحفظ اسعار الطاقه مع الاستثمار في تزويد
اوكرانيا
وانا بعد
اداره
معروس في حوار على مستويات عليا لتوضيح
عواقب الاستخدام المحتمل للاسلحه النوويه
نحن على تواصل مع الروس من اجل تخفيض
المخاطر وتقليص اللجوء الى السلاح الذري
بشان الدعم الامريكي
دعم قوي في الكونغرس لتقديم المعدات
اللازمه لاوكرانيا للدفاع عن نفسها
كريستيانو
في تقديري لا يزال التايد قويا في
الكونغرس لتقديم الموارد اللازمه
الاوكرانيا
تنقطع فيها المساعدات نعم قد تتزايد
الاصوات التي تطرح تساؤلات ولكنها ستظل
اقليه معزوله
من بينها سفاره الروسيه في واشنطن وسفاره
الولايات المتحده في موسكو
البيت الابيض
ان الولايات المتحده تحتفظوا بالحق في
اجراء المحادثات بشكل مباشر مع روسيا بشان
القضايا المهمه
نحتفظ بالحق في التحدث بشكل مباشر على
المستويات العليا بشان القضايا التي تهم
الولايات المتحده وهذا ما حدث خلال الاشهر
القليله الماضيه محادثاتنا ركزت فقط على
الحد من المخاطر والعلاقات بين الولايات
المتحده وروسيا نواصل التمسك بمبادئنا
الاساسيه المتمثله في عدم اتخاذ اي قرارات
دون العوده الاوكرانيا حرصنا على حمايه
التوقيت المحادثات ومحتواها حتى نتمتع
بالقدره المستمره على التواصل مع موسكو
وعلى عدم قطع خطوط الاتصال معها
روسيا وان موقفها معروف
الروسيه الى الانسحاب اولا من اوكرانيا
قبل الحديث عن اي تفاوض
للمفاوضات وقال ان وكران تتحدث مع رئيس
الروسي القادم وفق تعبيره
على صعيد